>> LAST TIME ON "TOP MODEL"...
>> MOROCCO!
>> WELCOME TO MARRAKECH.
>> (high-pitched voice) NO, NO,
NO!
IT'S SO NOT AMERICA.
>> (growls)
>> MODEL THROUGH IT.
IT JUST LOOKS SO CONTRIVED.
IT'S KILLING ME.
>> TURN YOUR SHOULDER
AWAY FROM ME.
THAT'S TOO MUCH BACK.
THAT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE FALLING OFF THE CAMEL.
NO.
>> SO WHO STAYS
IN THIS COMPETITION?
ALEXANDRIA.
KASIA WAS ELIMINATED.
FOUR GIRLS REMAIN--
HANNAH, ALEXANDRIA,
MOLLY, AND BRITTANI--
ALL FIGHTING TO LAND ON
THE PAGES OF ITALIAN "VOGUE."
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ON TOP ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> ♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT HOT ♪
♪ GET IT UP ♪
♪ YOU KNOW ♪
♪ THAT WE DON'T STOP ♪
♪ NA, AND WHEN YOU GET IT HOT ♪
♪ NA, YOU GOTTA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
WANNA BE ON TOP?
WHOO!
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
(static hisses)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (speaks Arabic)
(snake hisses)
>> TEN GIRLS HAVE GONE HOME.
THAT'S INSANE.
>> THAT'S SO WEIRD.
>> ONLY FOUR CAN CONTINUE ON.
>> THE SAGA OF THE MODELS.
>> OH! LOOK IT.
>> (singsongy) OOH!
>> OOH!
>> "HIGH FASHION PRINCESS
ON HER OWN."
>> I LOOK LIKE I GOT A 'DONK.
>> YOU GOT 'DONK.
>> BADONKADONK.
>> I GOT A BUM.
>> I GOT FIRST PHOTO.
IT WAS PRETTY AWESOME.
LIKE, WE'RE IN MOROCCO.
WE'RE FINAL FOUR.
AND I REALLY THINK
I'LL GET TO THE TOP TWO.
HA HA HA HA HA HA!
>> I DEFINITELY FEEL LIKE
I'M STILL PUSHING MYSELF,
BUT THE FACT
THAT I'VE HAD TO DO THAT
AND I'VE HAD TO KEEP
RAISING MY BAR FOR MYSELF
MEANS A LOT TO ME
BECAUSE IT MEANS I'VE DONE
MORE THAN I EXPECTED.
>> BEING IN THE BOTTOM TWO
FOR THE SECOND TIME,
I AM VERY NERVOUS.
>> ALEXANDRIA, THE JUDGES
AREN'T SURE IF THEY CAN TRUST
YOUR DEMEANOR ON SET.
>> AND I'M JUST
REALLY DISAPPOINTED IN MYSELF,
BUT I'M VERY HAPPY
THAT I GOT A SECOND CHANCE.
AND I REALLY NEED
TO PROVE MYSELF.
LIKE YOU, EACH OF YOU,
I'M, FOR SURE,
FEEL VERY, VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT THIS...
>> MM.
>> LIKE, I DO,
AND I'M VERY GLAD IT'S US
THAT ARE HERE.
>> I KNOW I CAN BEAT
THIS COMPETITION.
I HAVE IT IN ME.
I HAVE A PERSONALITY.
I MEAN, I'M FREAKING IN MOROCCO,
FINAL FOUR.
IT'S INSANE.
IT'S CRAZY 'CAUSE WE ALL
KINDA STAND FOR SOMETHING
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
>> LIKE WHAT?
>> WELL, YOU'RE LIKE
THE CALIFORNIA SURFER GIRL.
YOU'VE GOT SOME SPICE,
LIKE, YOU'VE GOT--YOU HAVE--
>> RIGHT. I HAVE--
I STAND FOR A LOT MORE, THOUGH.
LIKE...
>> WELL, YEAH.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THAT--
YOU HAVE YOUR, LIKE, BACKSTORY.
>> I HAVE MY REASONS FOR THIS...
>> YEAH.
>> AND I WANNA CHANGE THE WORLD
ONE DAY.
>> AND THEN, BRITTANI,
I NEVER THOUGHT I'D MEET
A GIRL FROM A TRAILER PARK.
YOU BREAK BOUNDARIES
FROM WHERE YOU COME FROM.
AND THEN MOLLY--
WELL, SHE'S JUST KIND OF, LIKE,
FREAKING SCARY.
>> (laughs)
>> SAY IT.
>> YOU DON'T WANNA PISS THAT...
>> I LOVE IT.
>> THAT BITCH OFF.
>> CRAZY BITCH.
>> SO I'M THE SCARY GIRL?
AWESOME.
I THINK I HAVE
A COUPLE OF PLACES
WHERE THE ANGER COMES FROM.
UM, I THINK BEING ADOPTED
GAVE ME SOME ISSUES,
YOU KNOW, ABANDONMENT ISSUES.
I WOULD PUSH BOUNDARIES.
>> YOU'RE HOME SLICE.
>> AND I'M THE GIRL NEXT DOOR.
>> EXACTLY. HOME SLICE.
>> BUT I WILL CUT YOU!
>> NONE OF US
HAVE THE SAME THING.
>> BUT I'LL CUT YOUR FACE,
BITCH!
>> I'LL CUT YOU.
(knock on door)
>> HI.
>> HEY.
>> HI, MISS J.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
OKAY, GIRLS,
TODAY WE HAVE A VERY,
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT CLIENT
THAT YOU'RE GONNA SEE,
AND I THINK
YOU'RE GONNA NEED THESE.
>> OOH.
>> SO, GIRLS,
YOU'RE GONNA FOLLOW ME.
WE'RE GONNA GO HAVE TEA.
SO THIS IS WHO YOU ARE...
>> HELLO.
>> SURPRISE.
IT'S FRANCA SOZZANI.
>> HI.
>> GIRLS, HAVE A SEAT.
IT'S TEA TIME.
>> FRANCA IS THE EDITOR IN CHIEF
OF "VOGUE ITALIA,"
SO IMPRESSING HER MEANS
MAYBE ANOTHER JOB
IN ITALIAN "VOGUE"
AFTER WINNING
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
>> IT'S NOT EVERY DAY
MODELS GET TO SIT DOWN
AND HAVE TEA
WITH FRANCA SOZZANI.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE YOU TO DO IS
TO SHOW FRANCA THE BOOKS.
>> WOULD YOU BOTH LIKE SOME TEA?
>> ACTUALLY,
I WOULD LOVE SOME TEA.
>> AND WHAT--WHAT ATTRACTS YOU
IN THIS WORK?
WHAT DO YOU THINK
IT CAN GIVE YOU, THIS WORK?
>> UH, I WANT TO MAKE IMAGES
THAT ARE IN A MAGAZINE
THAT YOU DON'T, LIKE,
FLIP THE PAGE AFTERWARDS.
YOU RIP 'EM OUT
AND YOU PUT 'EM ON YOUR WALL.
I THINK THE WHOLE--
JUST THE WHOLE WORLD OF FASHION
IS AMAZING.
WELL, HOW DID YOU
GET STARTED AT "VOGUE"?
>> I START, UH, LIKE YOU,
BY CHANCE. (chuckles)
YEAH, DO YOU KNOW THAT IT IS
NOT EASY WORK, ALL OF YOU?
SO YOU HAVE TO USE
REALLY MORE YOUR PERSONALITY,
AND EVEN IF IT'S A MISTAKE
IN YOUR BODY--YOU THINK,
"OH, I DON'T LIKE MY TEETH
OR I DON'T LIKE MY LEGS"--
DOESN'T MATTER.
TRY TO FIND A WAY--
A WAY THAT YOU REALLY BECOME
A-A PLUS.
>> I'M BRITTANI.
>> BUT WHERE ARE YOU FROM?
>> I'M FROM
BEECH CREEK, PENNSYLVANIA.
VERY, VERY, VERY SMALL TOWN.
>> HOW MANY OF YOU
REALLY LOOKED AT ITALIAN "VOGUE"
BEFORE BEING
IN THIS COMPETITION?
>> NOW IT'S ONLINE.
SO YOU CAN EVEN SEE IT ONLINE.
>> YEAH, THAT'S THE GREAT THING.
I LOVE EZINES.
>> YEAH, I LOVE THE INTERNET.
>> MY MOM, LIKE, MADE FUN OF ME
FOR BEING A HOARDER
BECAUSE I WOULD GET
AMERICAN "VOGUE" IN THE MAIL,
AND I'D SAVE EVERY SINGLE ISSUE
OF MY "VOGUE" UNDER MY BED.
SHE WAS LIKE,
"THIS IS A PROBLEM.
YOU'RE RUNNING OUT OF ROOM.
JUST THROW THEM AWAY.
YOU DON'T NEED THEM."
I'M LIKE,
"YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND."
>> I FELT LIKE I KEPT CATCHING
FRANCA LOOKING AT BRITTANI,
AND I FELT LIKE MAYBE
I DIDN'T STAND OUT AS MUCH
AS I COULD HAVE OR SHOULD HAVE.
>> I'M ALEXANDRIA.
WELL, WHAT'S BEEN
YOUR FAVORITE PART?
>> THE PHOTOGRAPHY, AND, UH,
I LIKE TO HAVE
THE GOOD RELATIONS
WITH THE PHOTOGRAPHERS.
I LIKE TO DISCOVER
PHOTOGRAPHERS.
OKAY.
>> DO YOU THINK
THE WHOLE EZINE THING
MIGHT BE A PROBLEM FOR, LIKE,
CONCRETE MAGAZINES,
THAT SOMEDAY
THEY MIGHT NOT PRINT ANYMORE
IF THEY HAVE THEM ONLINE?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
>> YOU DON'T THINK SO?
I THINK I COULD HAVE
STOOD OUT MORE,
BUT I DIDN'T WANT TO OVERSHINE
ANYBODY ELSE,
BUT MOLLY DIDN'T REALLY
TALK A LOT AT ALL.
>> OKAY, NOW YOU'RE LUCKY
YOU'RE HERE,
AND FROM NOW,
THERE WILL BE,
OF COURSE, ONE WINNER.
AND, UH, IF, UH, YOU DON'T WIN,
DON'T THINK
THAT IT'S OVER FOR YOU.
FROM HERE YOU START.
>> THANK YOU
FOR HAVING TEA WITH US.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> IT WAS WEIRD HAVING HER
RIGHT THERE IN FRONT OF US.
I DON'T KNOW. IT WAS--
IT WAS PRETTY INTIMIDATING.
>> SO, GIRLS,
ONCE AGAIN,
I HAVE SOMEONE VERY SPECIAL
I WOULD LIKE FOR YOU TO MEET.
NOOR?
(Moroccan music playing)
>> OHH!
>> IT'S THE FIRST TIME
I'VE EVER SEEN SOMEONE
BALANCE A WHOLE ENTIRE TEA SET
ON YOUR HEAD.
IT WAS...
VERY CULTURAL.
>> SHE'S A PROFESSIONAL
TEA TRAY DANCER.
>> HI, GIRLS.
BEING ABLE TO DANCE
AND MOVE YOUR BODY
WHILE HAVING A FULL TRAY
ON YOUR HEAD
REQUIRES A GREAT BALANCE
AND DEXTERITY.
>> OOH.
>> IT TOTALLY MAKES SENSE
THAT WE'RE BALANCING
SOMETHING ON OUR HEADS.
IT'S A COOL SPIN
ON THE WHOLE, LIKE, OLD-SCHOOL
WALKING WITH BOOKS ON YOUR HEAD.
>> SO, GIRLS, GRAB A TRAY.
>> I HAVE VERY GOOD POSTURE
AND I HAVE A VERY BIG HEAD.
IT'S, UH, IT'S A LITTLE FLAT
ON TOP,
SO, UM, IT SITS PERFECTLY.
>> HEAD MUST BE CORRECT AND UP.
SHOULDERS ON THE SAME BALANCE.
>> MY HEAD IS, LIKE,
POINTY ON THE TOP.
>> OH!
OH, NO!
>> IF, UM...
>> DAMN IT!
>> NO!
>> IF THE TRAY
FALLS OFF OF YOUR HEAD,
YOU STILL WANNA KEEP
YOUR COMPOSURE.
YOU STILL WANNA BE FIERCE.
YOU WANNA BE FABULOUS.
>> BRITTANI WAS DROPPING IT
EVERYWHERE.
LIKE, EVERY 15 SECONDS,
I WOULD JUST HEAR
CLANK CLANK EVERYWHERE.
>> LET'S, UM...
>> DAMN IT!
>> NO! OH!
SORRY.
>> YOU KNOW, I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET IT TO EVEN SIT
ON MY HEAD,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
I GOT PROGRESSIVELY BETTER
AND BETTER.
>> SHOULDERS.
>> AAH!
>> KEEP IT.
ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR.
>> THREE, FOUR.
>> THIS TEA-BALANCING DANCE--
LITERALLY VERY SENSUAL
BUT VERY CLASSY,
ALL VERY PRETTY MOVEMENTS
IN THE HANDS.
YEAH! YEAH! YEAH! YEAH!
>> RIGHT. (speaks indistinctly)
>> LIKE, HEY! YEAH! YEAH! YEAH!
>> LIKE, ALEXANDRIA--
SHE GOES OVERBOARD
WITH A LOT OF THINGS.
>> (singsongy) KEEP
YOUR MODEL COMPOSURE!
>> OHH!
MIGHT AS WELL JUST--
JUST GLUE THIS.
I DANCED FOR TEN YEARS,
AND I DIDN'T EXPECT FOR IT
TO BE SO DIFFICULT FOR ME
TO DANCE WITH A TRAY OF TEA
ON MY HEAD.
>> SO, GIRLS,
NOOR AND I HAVE ONE MORE THING.
YOU GIRLS WILL BE PERFORMING
WHAT YOU JUST PRACTICED
TONIGHT,
IN FRONT OF A LIVE AUDIENCE.
>> I WISH I WOULD HAVE
BEEN BETTER AT IT
BECAUSE I WASN'T LOOKING FORWARD
TO MAKING AN ASS OUT OF MYSELF.
>> OVER HERE
WE HAVE SOME OUTFITS FOR YOU.
SO, GIRLS, LET'S GO GET DRESSED.
>> SEE YOU TONIGHT.
>> IT'S GETTING
MORE AND MORE IMPORTANT
TO DO EXTREMELY WELL.
THERE'S A LOT OF PRESSURE
ON ALL OF US RIGHT NOW,
AND EVEN THE LITTLE,
SMALLEST MISTAKE IS
GONNA SEND SOMEONE PACKING.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> MY TEACUP'S ALL...
DINGED.
GOT TO GET INTO
THE RIGHT CLOTHES FOR THIS.
>> OH, WOW.
YOU'RE STRIPPING
AND BALANCING TEA.
>> THIS IS MY--
THE SEXINESS COMING OUT.
OKEYDOKEY.
>> (laughs) YOU'RE FUNNY.
>> WHAT?
(tray clatters)
>> DAMN IT!
AFTER WE HAVE
THIS BALANCING LESSON,
UM, NOOR AND MISS J. TELL US
THAT WE'RE GONNA END UP
PERFORMING
A TEA TRAY-BALANCING DANCE
IN FRONT OF A LIVE AUDIENCE.
♪♪♪♪♪
(brakes squeal)
>> LADIES,
WELCOME TO LE COMPTOIR.
THIS IS THE PLACE
THAT LOCALS AND EVEN TOURISTS
FILL NIGHTLY
TO SEE THE FAMOUS
TEA TRAY DANCE.
>> BUT...
YOU WON'T DANCE ALONE.
>> GIRLS, YOU WILL BE DANCING
WITH THESE...
PROFESSIONAL DANCERS.
>> NO.
>> BUT THERE'S ONE THING
I FORGOT TO TELL YOU.
YOU WILL BE WALKING
WITH THE LIT CANDLES
AS WELL.
NOOR AND I WILL CHOOSE
THE WINNER,
AND THE WINNER OF THIS CHALLENGE
WILL GET
A ONE-ON-ONE WALKING LESSON
WITH NONE OTHER THAN ME.
IT'S VERY RARE A GIRL GETS
A ONE-ON-ONE WITH ME.
SO, GIRLS, GO GET READY.
>> I'M NOT VERY THRILLED
ABOUT THE WHOLE, LIKE,
CANDLES ON MY HEAD THING.
I MEAN, I'M JUST REALLY AFRAID
THAT I'M GONNA BURN
THE PLACE DOWN.
>> OKAY, GIRLS, SO IT'S VERY,
VERY, VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
THAT YOU GIRLS REALLY
KINDA NAIL THIS AS BEST YOU CAN,
OKAY, BECAUSE RIGHT NOW,
IT'S DOWN TO THE WIRE.
THERE'S ONLY FOUR
OF YOU BITCHES LEFT.
AND ONLY ONE OUT OF THE FOUR
CAN BECOME
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> WE ARE ABOUT TO DO
THE WALKING WITH THE TEAPOT
AND NOW FIRE
ON TOP OF OUR HEADS,
AND...
PLEASE.
I WAS MADE TO DO THIS.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (cheering)
>> (trilling)
♪♪♪♪♪
(applause)
>> (bleep).
(bleep).
I'M WALKING DOWNSTAIRS,
AND I TRIP ON MY SKIRT.
AND MISS J. WAS LIKE,
"IF THINGS FALL OFF, YOU KNOW,
YOU CAN PICK THEM UP
AND BE CUTE."
AND I WAS JUST LIKE,
"SCREW THIS."
I WAS SO ANGRY AT THAT POINT,
I WAS LIKE, "I'M NOT PICKING
(bleep) UP."
>> MOLLY--WHEN SHE TRIPPED,
HE FACE BECAME A BIT TIGHT
AND A BIT ANGRY,
AND IT STAYED THAT WAY
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE MOVEMENT
OF THE DANCE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I TRIPPED ON MY SKIRT.
>> IT'S OKAY.
>> NO, IT'S NOT (bleep) OKAY.
>> I THINK BRITTANI...
>> MY GOD.
>> YEAH.
>> SHE'S--TRANSFORMATION.
START TO MOVE...
>> AND SHE STARTED DANCING
AND SHE WAS MOVING.
>> AND SHE DIDN'T FALL DOWN,
HER TRAY.
>> HER TRAY--
SHE DIDN'T DROP HER TRAY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I'M JUST--
I'M, LIKE, HUMILIATED.
I DON'T LIKE LOOKING
LIKE AN IDIOT, AND I TOTALLY
LOOKED LIKE AN IDIOT,
AND IT PISSED ME OFF.
>> OH, YEAH!
>> I HEAR THEM ALL
CLAPPING FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
I BARELY GOT ANY CLAPS
'CAUSE I SUCKED.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I DON'T REALLY HAVE, LIKE,
THE HIP MOVEMENT,
SO I JUST KIND OF TRIED TO, UM,
MAYBE DO THE WAVE. (chuckles)
>> (trilling)
>> DOWN.
>> I WONDER
WHO'S GONNA WIN THIS ONE.
>> ALEXANDRIA--
SHE WAS VERY, VERY, UH,
POWERFUL.
>> MM.
>> I MEAN, ALEXANDRIA'S
DOING PRETTY WELL,
BUT, LIKE, IF YOU LOOK
AT ALEXANDRIA'S HEAD,
IT'S, LIKE, FLAT ON THE TOP,
AND I'M LIKE, THAT'S UNFAIR.
>> (trilling)
>> HA HA HA.
(teacups clatter)
>> OOH!
>> I WAS DOING SO WELL.
I DID HAVE A LITTLE TRIP.
ONE OF THE GENTLEMEN
PUT THE TEAPOT BACK ON MY HEAD.
MOST OF ALL,
I WAS REALLY MEMORABLE,
AND I SMILED THROUGH
THE WHOLE THING.
>> SHE DROPPED
HER ENTIRE THING, SO...
THEY STILL LIKE HER.
>> ALEXANDRIA--
SHE BECAME TOO CONFIDENT.
>> YES.
>> SHE FELT THE AUDIENCE
GETTING INTO HER,
AND IT'S WHEN SHE JUST GOT
A LITTLE--
DID THAT ONE THING EXTRA.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OKAY, GIRLS,
I'M GONNA START WITH MOLLY.
GOOD GOLLY, MISS MOLLY.
>> YEAH.
>> HOW DID YOU FEEL
AFTER YOU HAD
YOUR FIRST LITTLE MISHAP?
>> IT WAS HORRIBLE.
I, LIKE, TRIPPED ON MY SKIRT
AND...
>> AND IT SHOWED IN YOUR FACE
THEN AND IT'S SHOWING
IN YOUR FACE NOW.
ALEXANDRIA, I LOVED
THE CONFIDENCE THAT YOU HAD
WHEN YOU CAME DOWN THOSE STEPS.
BUT THE MOMENT YOU KIND--
GIRL, THE MOMENT YOU CAME DOWN,
GIRL,
>> I DIDN'T DROP IT LIKE THAT.
>> YOU BECAME REALCONFIDENT.
NOW MISS BRITTANI, GIRL,
I WAS PLEASANTLY SURPRISED.
YOU CAME STRAIGHT THROUGH,
SHAKING, SHIMMYING,
WIGGLING, AND TWISTING,
AND NOT A THING
FELL OFF YOUR HEAD.
HANNAH.
>> HANNAH.
>> YOU ARE THREE CYCLES BEHIND.
CYCLE 13, I THINK, WAS HAWAII.
'CAUSE, GIRL,
YOU ABOUT TO HULA HOO.
YOU ABOUT TO HULA YOUR WAY
THROUGH THE MOROCCANS' HEART.
SO NOW...
OKAY, YOU READY?
>> FIRST, LET ME TELL YOU
THAT ALEXANDRIA IS
THE RUNNER-UP.
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO...
THE BARE TRAY ON THE HEAD
TACTICS,
THE WINNER IS...
BRITTANI.
SO YOU'RE THE WINNER.
>> (trills)
>> TO WIN A CHALLENGE
A CHALLENGE THIS LATE
IN THE COMPETITION
AND GET TO WORK WITH MISS J.
ON MY RUNWAY,
IT'S DEFINITELY GONNA BE,
LIKE, A PLUS UP.
I'M DEFINITELY EXCITED.
>> NOW YOU CAN UTILIZE
THIS TIME
FOR YOURSELF
OR PICK ONE
OF THE OTHER THREE GIRLS
TO SHARE IT WITH YOU.
IT'S UP TO YOU.
>> UM, I'M GONNA HAVE
HANNAH COME WITH ME.
I DON'T WANNA, LIKE,
SAY IT IN A MEAN WAY,
BUT I KNOW HANNAH
NEEDS IT THE MOST
AND I KNOW
SHE WANTED IT THE MOST.
>> CHALLENGES REALLY HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH
WHO GOES HOME.
SO I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT IT.
I KNOW I CAN TAKE
BETTER PICTURES
THAN EVERYONE ELSE.
AND SO IT WAS (bleep)
TEA ON MY HEAD. REALLY?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I'M REALLY THANKFUL AND HAPPY
THAT BRITTANI CHOOSES ME.
SO ME AND BRITTANI ARRIVE
AT THIS MAGNIFICENT GARDEN.
>> GIRLS.
PUT DOWN YOUR PURSES.
I WANT YOU TO START TO WALK.
BRITTANI, GIVE ME MORE SPEED.
YOU CAN MAKE IT
A LITTLE BIT STRONGER.
AND JUST RELAX.
YOU'RE NOT--YOU'RE NOT RELAXED.
YOU LOSE YOUR BALANCE
AND YOU TRY TO TURN
AND HAVE YOUR FEET THIS WAY,
THIS HAPPENS.
YOU WANT THE FOOT BEHIND YOU
TO BE...
NOW ALL YOUR WEIGHT GOES HERE.
NOW WE MADE YOU
SOMETHING REALLY SPECIAL
FOR FINAL RUNWAY,
AND THAT FINAL RUNWAY IS
GONNA BE
MORE OF AN INTIMATE SETTING.
FOR EXAMPLE,
YOU MAY COME OUT OF ONE ROOM
AND GO INTO ANOTHER ROOM.
SO PRACTICE THIS--
A HALF TURN.
>> WHAT AM I DOING WRONG?
>> WHAT YOU'RE DOING WRONG IS
YOU'RE NOT--
YOU'RE DOING A STOP...
>> STOP.
>> AND THEN TURN.
>> OKAY.
>> IT SHOULD BE A TURN
AND STOP.
>> I REALLY NEEDED THAT,
AND IT'S GONNA GIVE ME
CONFIDENCE TO KNOW
THAT THERE ARE THINGS
THAT MISS J. LOOKED AT
AND TOLD ME TO WORK ON,
AND I CAN CHANGE THEM
AND GET STRONGER ON THE RUNWAY.
>> THOSE ARE
YOUR "MISS J.'s TIPS"
FOR THE DAY.
>> THANK YOU, MISS J,
>> THANK YOU.
>> GET OUTTA HERE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I NEED TO EAT SOMETHING.
THAT PLACE LOOKS
REALLY AUTHENTIC
AND INTERESTING.
AFTER THE RUNWAY TEACH,
WE'RE WALKING THROUGH THE SOUK.
WE COME ACROSS THIS RESTAURANT.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> THERE IS BRAINS ON THE TABLE.
>> (high-pitched voice) OH,
MY GOD!
>> THERE WAS, LIKE,
A GOAT'S HEAD ON THE TABLE,
BRAINS, EYEBALLS.
>> THAT'S AN EYEBALL?
>> YEAH.
>> UGH!
>> (laughs)
>> THAT'S SO GROSS, MAN.
>> OH, LET ME SEE.
>> LET'S EAT BRAIN.
DO WE EAT IT WITH OUR HANDS?
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> ALL RIGHT.
OKAY, READY, YOU GUYS?
TOP FOUR.
>> DUDE.
>> AAH!
>> OKAY, READY?
>> OH, NO. WAIT.
>> ONE... TWO... THREE.
>> THE TEXTURE OF A BRAIN IS
JUST SQUISHY AND GOOEY
AND DISGUSTING.
AND IT WAS JUST
NOT EVEN, LIKE, COOKED.
IT WAS JUST GROSS
AND DISGUSTING.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OH!
>> (singsongy) TYRA MAIL!
>> "AH, THE SWEET SMELL
OF SOUKCES."
>> "LOVE, TYRA."
>> WHAT?
>> WE'RE GONNA BE SHOOTING
SOMEWHERE REALLY STINKY.
>> YEAH.
>> MAYBE.
>> MAYBE WE'RE DOING
SOMETHING IN THE MARKET,
AND THEN WE GET TO GO SHOPPING
AGAIN.
>> YAY!
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I'M NOT EATING THIS.
>> YOU'RE NOT? I'LL EAT IT.
>> THE TEXTURE OF A GOAT BRAIN--
IT'S DISGUSTING.
IT MESSED UP
MY WHOLE DIGESTIVE SYSTEM.
UGH! AND NOW I'M JUST
REALLY (bleep) SICK.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
FOR SOME REASON,
I FELT REALLY WRONG
ABOUT EATING THE EYEBALL.
>> (sighs)
I WANNA GO TO BED.
I DON'T FEEL GOOD.
TOMORROW, I'M PRETTY SURE
WE HAVE A SHOOT.
I'M JUST WAITING
FOR MYSELF TO THROW UP.
IF I'M LIKE THIS TOMORROW,
I'M NOT SURE
HOW I'M GONNA PULL IT OFF.
(whines)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I WANNA, LIKE,
GO BACK TO THE MARKETPLACE
AND JUST SPEND ALL MY MONEY.
>> I WAKE UP IN THE MORNING,
AND I FEEL REALLY SICK
AND I'M JUST WAITING
FOR MYSELF TO THROW UP.
GOAT BRAIN--IT'S DISGUSTING.
IT'S GONNA BE A HUGE STRUGGLE
FOR ME TODAY
TO, LIKE, REALLY PERFORM.
>> LOCK AND LOAD.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> GOOD MORNING.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS?
>> GREAT.
>> WELL, WE'RE HERE
IN THE MEDINA,
WHICH IS THE LARGEST SOUK,
OR OUTDOOR MARKET,
IN MOROCCO.
BUT FOR YOUR SHOOT,
WE'RE LITERALLY GONNA BE
DOWN IN THE MARKET.
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA BE STYLED
IN THE DESIGNS BY ISSA LONDON,
WHO HAS DRESSED
SCARLETT JOHANSSON,
ALSO ROYAL KATE MIDDLETON.
AND REMEMBER,
WE WANNA CONTINUE THE JOURNEY.
LAST WEEK, WE WERE ON CAMELS
IN THE DESERT.
WE WANT THAT STORY TO CONTINUE.
NOW YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER TODAY--
HE IS A LEGEND.
HE WAS FLOWN IN FROM PARIS.
HE HAS SHOT MANY SUPERMODELS.
HE WAS THE CREATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR "MARIE CLAIRE" FRANCE--
FRIEDEMANN HAUSS.
THESE ARE
YOUR FOUR LUCKY LADIES.
SO NOW WHAT CAN YOU
TALK TO THEM ABOUT
IN TERMS OF BRINGING THE STORY
AND THE ENERGY IN THIS MARKET
FOR THE SHOOT TODAY?
>> YOU SHOULD, UH,
DO SOME MOVEMENT HERE.
YOU HAVE TO IMMERSE YOURSELF
INTO THE LOCAL CULTURE.
>> FRIEDEMANN HAUSS--
HE IS THEMAN.
HE HAS SHOT WITH, LIKE,
SO MANY SUPERMODELS.
I MEAN, HE'S A BIG SHOT.
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
>> SO LET'S GO DOWN
TO HAIR AND MAKEUP
AND GET YOU GUYS ALL STYLED UP.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> LET'S DO IT.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> BRITTANI APPEARS
TO BE GETTING SLEEP.
OR ARE YOU STILL JET-LAGGED?
>> N--OH, NO,
I'M NOT JET-LAGGED.
I JUST WAS, LIKE,
KIND OF SICK LAST NIGHT.
SO I'M JUST TAKING THIS TIME
TO BE CHILL
AND THEN BRING MYSELF TOGETHER.
>> THAT'S OKAY.
>> I'LL BE READY.
>> SO, GIRL, TODAY IS
GONNA BE, LIKE,
SOMETHING REALLY HIGH COUTURE.
>> GREAT.
>> YEAH.
>> THE CONCEPT FOR THE SHOOT
TODAY IS CONTINUING THE STORY
OF THE FASHION CARAVAN.
THIS WEEK I NEED TO SHOW UP
100%, LIKE,
BRING EVERYTHING I'VE GOT.
>> YOU LOOK GORGEOUS.
YOU LOOK SPECTACULAR.
>> I LOOK...
>> I REALLY WANT YOU
TO FEEL INSPIRED
BY THE ENVIRONMENT.
THAT STORY, THAT INSPIRATION,
THAT JOURNEY
HAS TO STILL COME ALIVE FOR YOU.
>> COOL.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> LOOK STRAIGHT.
>> LIVE IN THAT MOMENT.
LIVE IN THAT MOMENT.
HANNAH, WHEN YOU'RE OUT HERE...
>> MM-HMM.
>> I THINK YOU'RE GETTING
A LITTLE LOST.
IT'S MORE OF A REAL MOMENT
AS OPPOSED TO
THIS WAFTY, WEIRD THING.
SO DOES THAT MAKE SENSE?
>> YEAH.
>> YOU OPEN THE DOOR AGAIN.
>> YOU SEE YOUR LOVE.
YOU TAKE A MOMENT.
>> I, LIKE,
IMAGINE THAT MY LOVER,
THE MAN THAT'S GONNA
ESCORT ME THROUGH THE CITY,
SO I, LIKE, START TRYING
TO ADD SOME ROMANCE
AND SOME, LIKE, EXCITEMENT
TO THE STORY...
>> RIGHT NOW YOU'RE LOOKING
VERY GLAZED THE WHOLE TIME.
DEER IN HEADLIGHTS.
>> BUT NOBODY, LIKE,
SEEMS TO BE, LIKE,
READING IT ON MY FACE.
>> COME OUT NOW. COME OUT.
>> THE PROBLEM WITH HANNAH IS
I THINK SHE GOT A LITTLE LOST.
SHE STARTED GETTING
A LITTLE AIRY FAIRY,
AND YOU KIND OF LOST
HER FEATURES A LITTLE BIT.
HANNAH, DIFFERENT EXPRESSIONS,
DIFFERENT MOMENTS.
IT'S A LITTLE LOST RIGHT NOW.
>> CAN YOU DO IT AGAIN?
HANNAH--SHE'S, UH, PRETTY,
BUT I THINK SHE DOES
A LITTLE BIT TOO MUCH.
SHE'S A LITTLE BIT POSE-Y.
>> YEAH, OKAY, HANNAH,
SO WE'RE--WE'RE GOOD.
MY ONLY THING IS THERE WAS,
LIKE, A BIG QUESTION MARK
ON YOUR FACE.
BUT, UM,
GO BACK TO WHAT YOU KNOW.
>> OKAY. COOL.
>> OKAY?
>> THANKS, MR. JAY.
>> ALL RIGHT, THANKS.
>> MR. JAY TELLS ME
IT LOOKS LIKE I HAVE
A QUESTION MARK ON MY FACE.
IT DEFINITELY FREAKS ME OUT.
>> HOW'D IT GO IN THERE?
>> UM, I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T THINK MR. JAY'S
TOO HAPPY WITH ME. (sighs)
I DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT WAS MISSING ON MY PART
TO REALLY DO MY JOB RIGHT,
AND I FEEL LIKE TODAY,
I DIDN'T DO, UM,
THE BEST THAT I COULD'VE DONE.
>> (snuffles)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> MOLLY.
>> HELLO THERE.
>> THIS IS KIND OF
YOUR AREA TO PLAY.
>> OKAY.
>> SO TRY NOT TO GO SO PROFILE.
JUST PLAY WITH IT.
>> YEAH, MY LAST TWO PICTURES
HAVE BEEN MY PROFILE, SO...
>> YEAH. YEAH.
>> WE JUST ALL HAVE
LITTLE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO FIX,
AND THE CHALLENGE IS GONNA BE
WHO CAN FIX IT?
WHO CAN GET THE BEST PICTURES?
AND I THINK IF IT'S ALL
BASED ON PICTURES,
I THINK I'M GONNA BE
IN THE TOP TWO,
'CAUSE I KNOW I CAN TAKE
SOME FRICKING PICTURES.
>> LET'S SHOOT IT.
BEAUTIFUL!
>> YEAH.
>> NOW DON'T SLOUCH DOWN.
JUST STILL KEEP IT STRETCHED.
ARCH THAT BACK,
LEAN INTO YOUR HIPS. YES.
>> MOLLY, UM,
I THINK SHE'S VERY BEAUTIFUL,
MODERN,
GOOD EDITORIAL GIRL.
COME DOWN. TH-THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S IT.
>> GORGEOUS.
>> GOOD, GOOD.
>> I'M BY THIS CARRIAGE,
AND THEN THERE'S
THIS HUGE CROWD OF PEOPLE.
>> VERY PRETTY.
>> I MEAN, HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
ALL KINDA STARING AT ME, LIKE,
"OOH, WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE?"
IT WAS PRETTY AWESOME, THOUGH.
>> SHE'S GOOD, NO?
>> YEAH. ALL RIGHT, WE'RE GOOD.
>> YAY!
>> ALEXANDRIA,
THE THING THAT JUST WORRIES ME
THE MOST--AND I--AND I'VE BEEN
VERY VOCAL ABOUT IT--
IS THAT WHEN YOU ARE ON CAMERA,
YOU HAVE TO LET GO.
AND I WOULD HATE TO GET
TO, YOU KNOW, THIS PLACE WHERE
WE DO A SHOOT TODAY WITH YOU,
AND IT'S SO CONTROLLED THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S GONNA
SEND YOU HOME.
>> MR. JAY DECIDES TO SAY,
"AND YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE
MISS CONTROLLING TODAY, RIGHT?"
>> ALL RIGHT?
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> OKAY.
>> (chuckles)
IT PISSED ME OFF.
I FEEL I AM LETTING GO
OF EVERY SINGLE REIN
THAT I HAVE.
I KNOW IF I JUST HAVE FUN
WITH IT IN MY HEART,
THAT I'LL DELIVER
SOME MAGIC STUFF.
>> DON'T FACE THE CAMERA
THAT WAY.
>> OKAY.
>> STRAIGHT. THE LIGHT IS THERE.
>> I FELT BEAUTIFUL.
I WAS FEELING THIS OUTFIT.
I FELT LIKE A PRINCESS
THAT WAS DISGUISED
AS A PRINCE.
IT WAS RAD.
>> WITH HER LIPS,
SHE'S NOT RELAXED.
>> IT'S THAT THING
SHE DOES ALL THE TIME
WITH HER FACE.
>> HER? YEAH.
>> YEAH. THAT SAID...
>> OUI, OUI, OUI.
>> BE COMFORTABLE.
>> YES.
>> BE WARY.
DON'T DO ANY EFFORT
WITH YOUR FACE.
OKAY.
>> DON'T LOSE YOUR NECK THERE,
ALEXANDRIA.
>> (flaps lips)
>> I GOT TO WATCH ALEXANDRIA,
AND SHE DID NOT DO SO HOT.
I'M SURE A LOT OF THE TIMES
I THINK SHE LOOKED LIKE...
WHICH IS NOT A GOOD THING.
>> FACE TO ME.
>> WHEN FRIEDEMANN TOLD ME
TO RELAX MY FACE,
I LOST THE FUN.
CONTROL STRUCK BACK.
IT SHOWED ON MY FACE.
>> I THINK WE GOT IT, NO?
>> IN MY HEART,
I GAVE IT MY ALL TODAY.
>> YOU'RE A MOVER.
YOU'RE A GOOD MOVER.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH. (kisses)
I HOPE I GOT A GOOD SHOT
FOR PANEL.
(thunder rumbles)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> FEELING GOOD?
>> I'LL BE FINE.
SAVING IT ALL FOR THE CAMERA.
>> COOL.
>> I JUST FEEL, LIKE,
REALLY BLAH RIGHT NOW,
BUT I'M NOT GONNA LET MY ILLNESS
KIND OF OVERSHADOW ME AT ALL.
HELLO.
>> IT'S GONNA BE
RIGHT ABOUT HERE.
>> AWESOME.
I'M GONNA DO THIS.
I DIDN'T COME HERE TO LOSE.
I CAME HERE TO WIN.
MY STORY IS I WAS
JUST VERY POWERFUL
AND I FOUND MY DESTINATION
WHILE I WAS ON THE CAMEL.
I SAW IT, AND NOW I'M HERE.
>> OKAY.
(man singing in Arabic)
>> YOU'RE TOO FAR
FROM THE LIGHT.
THE FIRST STEP--YEAH, YEAH.
>> YEAH, IT LOOKS GOOD,
BRITTANI.
BEAUTIFUL.
>> YEAH, SUPER.
>> BRITTANI CERTAINLY HAD
THE CHALLENGE
OF WORKING WITH THE RAIN,
BUT JUST THE WAY
BRITTANI MOVED DOWN THE STAIRS
AND CARESSED THE WOODEN DOOR
AND KIND OF BENT HER BODY
OVER IT--IT'S, LIKE,
I REALLY BELIEVED THAT
SHE REACHED THIS DESTINATION.
I LOVE THE BODY LANGUAGE.
OH, I LOVE THE LITTLE SMILE.
>> NICE. BEAUTIFUL.
BRITTANI--SHE HAS
A LOT OF NATURAL ELEGANCE,
MOVING VERY NICELY.
SHE GAVE ME
A-A LOT OF INSPIRATION.
>> OKAY.
THAT'S A WRAP, EVERYBODY.
>> MERCI.
>> GREAT JOB, BRITTANI.
GOOD JOB IN THE RAIN.
>> THANK YOU.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I'M HOPING
I CAN JUST NOT WORK,
'CAUSE AFTER THIS EXPERIENCE,
I'M DEFINITELY GONNA NEED
TWO MONTHS
TO JUST LOAF AROUND.
OOH!
NO!
>> SAY IT AIN'T SO!
>> "TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 3 WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPE OF BECOMING"...
>> AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (chuckles)
>> AND THERE'S ONLY THREE OF US.
HOW FREAKING INSANE IS THAT?
>> VERY (bleep) WEIRD, DUDE.
>> THAT'S JUST INSANE.
>> I'M GONNA GO THROW UP.
>> THAT'S CRAZY.
>> I'M NOT NERVOUS REALLY.
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW.
I GOT GREAT FEEDBACK.
BOTH MR. JAY
AND THE PHOTOGRAPHER
WERE REALLY LIKING MY STUFF.
ALEXANDRIA DID BADLY.
I JUST DON'T REALLY SEE HER
AS A HIGH FASHION MODEL.
SHE DIDN'T DO SO WELL,
SO I THINK SHE'S PROBABLY
GOING HOME.
>> (blows raspberry)
I AM VERY NERVOUS
ABOUT PANEL.
I GOT POSITIVE FEEDBACK TODAY,
BUT IN A WAY,
I-I DON'T KNOW FOR SURE.
I FEEL LIKE I DID,
I FEEL LIKE I GAVE IT MY ALL,
AND I AM HAPPY NO MATTER WHAT
ON THAT NOTE,
BECAUSE I DID MY BEST,
AND I MADE MYSELF HAPPY.
>> WE ALL DID AWESOME,
BUT AT THIS POINT,
OUR BEST ISN'T ENOUGH
'CAUSE THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR THEBEST OUT OF THE GROUP,
AND WE CAN'T ALL BE PERFECT.
I FELT PRETTY CONFIDENT,
BUT I FEEL CONFIDENT
A LOT OF TIMES,
AND WHAT I LIKE
AND WHAT PANEL LIKES
ARE COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THINGS.
JAY SAID THAT I TOLD HIM A STORY
AND THAT HE REALLY LIKED
WHAT WAS GOING ON,
AND SO I MET EVERY GOAL
I WANTED TO MEET.
>> IT'S ONE OF OURS LAST NIGHT.
>> IT HAS TO BE SOMEBODY.
>> HOW WAS IT SO BAD?
WHY WAS IT SO BAD THAT
YOU THINK IT'S YOUR LAST NIGHT?
>> BECAUSE MR. JAY SAID
I HAD A QUESTION MARK
ON MY FACE.
>> WELL, IT WAS JUST
A QUESTION MARK FACE.
WHY DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE GOING HOME?
NO, NO, NO. HANNAH, NO.
>> TODAY D--
WAS NOT A GOOD DAY FOR ME.
I DON'T KNOW.
(voice breaks) I JUST REALLY
WANTED TO SHOW IMPROVEMENT TODAY
OR, LIKE, SHOW,
LIKE, A DIFFERENT STRENGTH.
I DID WHAT MR. JAY
AND FRIEDEMANN
WERE TELLING ME TO DO.
I DIDN'T, LIKE,
MODEL TO MY FULL POTENTIAL
AND I DIDN'T BRING MYSELF
TO THE SHOOT.
IT'S JUST REALLY SCARY.
IT'S SOMEBODY'S LAST NIGHT.
IT'S REALLY INSANE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WHAT?
>> I WANT YOU TO TAKE THESE
AND TRY THESE ON
AND SEE IF YOU LIKE THEM.
>> OH, THIS IS LOVELY.
NO, NO, THIS IS LOVELY.
OH, THIS IS SO ME.
>> OH, IT'S SO YOU?
>> NO, I LOVE THIS.
>> THIS WAS MADE IN MOROCCO.
>> IT'S LOVELY.
HELLO, LADIES.
>> HI.
>> OUR SECOND WEEK IN...
(deepens voice) MARRAKECH.
(normal voice) YOU KNOW
OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH IMG MODELS, ONE OF THETOP
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD,
A SPREAD IN "VOGUE ITALIA,"
A COVER OF "BEAUTY IN VOGUE,"
LIKE OUR CYCLE 15 WINNER ANN,
AND A SPREAD
AND PROMINENT FEATURESHIP
WITHIN vogue.it,
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES--
THE FIRST IS
THE NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
NIGEL BARKER...
>> HEY.
>> THE SEXIFIED
ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY,
MOST INFLUENTIAL PERSON
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
AND THEN WE HAVE
DANIELLA ISSA HELAYEL,
AND HER CLOTHES ARE
THE ONES YOU WORE
ON YOUR PHOTO SHOOT.
ARE WE READY TO START JUDGING?
LET'S GO.
ALL RIGHT.
ALEXANDRIA.
YOU WERE PHOTOGRAPHED
IN THE MEDINA.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> DANIELLA,
THESE CLOTHES ARE WONDERFUL.
ALEXANDRIA, YOU LOOK
AS IF YOU'VE LOST YOUR MIND.
>> IN A GOOD WAY OR BAD WAY?
>> IT'S INTERESTING WAY.
I'M TRYING TO HOOK
INTO THE NARRATIVE.
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?
>> I WAS WITH A HAT AND VEST
AND PANTS, SO I WAS PICTURING
MORE LIKE I WAS IN A DISGUISE--
PRINCESS BOY--
BEING IN THE MARKETPLACE.
>> ALEXANDRIA, I ACTUALLY THINK
YOU LOOK VERY BEAUTIFUL
IN THIS PICTURE.
ALTHOUGH, I WISH YOU'D JUST DONE
A LITTLE BIT MORE
WITH YOUR BODY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE STORY.
>> I THINK HER EYES LOOK
VERY MYSTERIOUS... SOMEHOW,
AND IT LOOKS VERY BEAUTIFUL.
I REALLY LIKE IT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> I'M--I'M NOT NECESSARILY
GETTING HIGH FASHION.
I'M GETTING
"CONDÉ NAST TRAVELER."
>> OKAY.
>> IN ORDER TO BE EDITORIAL,
IN ORDER OT HAVE AN EDGE,
YOU'VE GOTTA ALMOST
DO THE REVERSE.
IF YOU'D ACTUALLY LOOK
A LITTLE BIT MORE MESSED UP,
DISGRUNTLED, COLLAPSED,
IT WOULD CREATE THAT MYSTERY.
>> IT WOULD TAKE YOU AWAY
FROM "CONDÉ NAST TRAVELER"
AND PUT YOU
ON "CONDÉ NAST VOGUE."
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> UP NEXT--BRITTANI,
WHO IS TRYING TO ROCK
A LITTLE MOROCCO
WITH THAT SCARF,
BUT IT IS CUTTING YOUR NECK OFF
AND MAKING YOU LOOK OLDER
THAN YOU ARE.
(laughs)
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
I LOVE THE WHOLE KIND OF
HIPS UP AGAINST THE WALL,
LOOKING AWAY,
ONE EYE SHOWING.
UNFORTUNATELY,
YOU COMPLETELY LOST
YOUR OTHER ARM.
>> YEAH.
>> AND AS A RESULT, IT LOOKS
AS IF YOU ACTUALLY MIGHT--
ACTUALLY BE MISSING AN ARM.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
A TOUCH OF ARM.
>> HERE'S A TOUCH OF ARM.
YOU CAN SEE THIS. LOOK AT THIS.
THERE'S YOUR--
THERE'S YOUR ARM. (laughs)
>> I LOVE IT, AND I--
THE MOST WONDERFUL THING IS
THE WAY YOU'VE BROKEN YOUR BODY.
>> I DON'T SEE
HIGH FASHION MAGAZINE,
BUT I THINK YOU'RE
A LITTLE BIT CLOSER
TO A HIGH FASHION MAGAZINE
THAN ALEXANDRIA POSSIBLY.
>> POSSIBLY.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> YES, YES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> NEXT UP IS HANNAH.
HANNAH, ARE YOU READY TO SEE
YOUR BEST SHOT IN THE MEDINA?
>> UNUSUAL. INTERESTING.
I ACTUALLY THINK THE--THE POSE
AND THE--THE BODY LANGUAGE
IS PERHAPS THE MOST EDITORIAL
OUT OF A-ANY OF THE PICTURES
I'VE SEEN SO FAR.
I WISH YOUR FACE, THOUGH,
HAD A DIFFERENT EXPRESSION,
A DIFFERENT LOOK.
I DON'T KNOW YOU'VE WORKED
YOUR ANGLES HERE.
>> I DISAGREE WITH YOU.
I THINK SHE LOOKS LOVELY TO ME.
>> 'CAUSE YOUR DRESS
IS LOOKING GOOD, GIRL.
>> AND THE CLOTHES
LOOK GREAT ON HER, THE DRESS.
I THINK HANNAH DID VERY WELL.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> AS WONDERFUL AS THE DRESS IS,
AS WONDERFUL AS YOUR LEG IS,
WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
SO FAR WE HAVE NOT HAD
A "WOW" MOMENT.
>> OKAY, HANNAH.
FASHION KIND OF LIKES EXTREMES.
YOU'RE KIND OF HERE NOR THERE
IN THIS PHOTO.
YOUR FACE IS NEITHER ANGULAR
NOR ROUND,
WHICH MAKES IT
KINDA JUST FALL FLAT.
YOU HAVE TO LEARN YOUR FACE
AND MAKE THE DECISION--
AM I GONNA SHOW
THE ROUNDNESS OF MY FACE?
AM I GONNA SHOW THE ANGLE?
WHAT AM I GOING TO DO?
OKAY?
>> YES. THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST--MOLLY.
>> DO YOU NOT LIKE MY SCARF
EITHER?
>> OH, T-THANK YOU.
TOSS IT EXTRAVAGANTLY.
YES.
>> YES.
>> MOLLY,
YOU WERE IN THE MEDINA.
LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> WELL, AT LAST...
>> THERE'S DRAMA HERE.
>> A FRANCA SOZZANI PAGE.
AND IT'S HIGH FASHION.
SHE IS CERTAINLY GIVING ME
AN ORIENTAL EXPRESS FEELING.
>> I LOVE YOUR BODY LANGUAGE,
THE WAY YOU POSE.
IT'S VERY NICE.
>> IT'S REAL DRAMA.
YOU'VE COMMITTED TO IT
THE WHOLE WAY, AND THAT'S IM--
THAT'S THE IMPORTANT PART
OF THIS, YOU KNOW,
IS THAT THERE'S SOMETHING THERE,
AS AN IMAGE TO BE SOLD
AS AN ADVERTISING CAMPAIGN,
AND I'M TAKEN SOMEWHERE.
>> YOU DO A GREAT JOB
OF SHOWING THE CLOTHES,
BUT NOT DOING IT IN A WAY
WHERE IT'S LIKE CATALOG.
"LOOK AT MY WATCH.
LOOK AT MY HEADBAND.
LOOK AT MY NECKLACE."
YOU KNOW, YOU DO IT IN A WAY
WHERE, "YEAH,
LOOK AT MY EARRINGS.
LOOK AT MY NECKLACE.
LOOK AT THIS DRESS.
LOOK AT THIS BRACELET.
LOOK AT THESE PANTS.
DON'T YOU WANT IT? YEAH.
AND I'M IN HIGH FASHION.
I'M IN ITALIAN 'VOGUE,' BABY.
WHAT?"
THAT'S WHAT YOU DO WELL.
THANK YOU, LADIES.
IT IS NOW TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
IS ELIMINATED.
(bell tolls)
>> ♪ HEY! ♪
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WE HAVE AN ELIMINATION
TO A DO.
>> MM-HMM.
>> A YOUNG FILLE...
(imitates French accent) MUST
GO HOME.
>> GO HOME.
TAKE THE CAMEL OUT OF HERE.
>> (normal voice) ALEXANDRIA.
>> I THINK THAT ALEXANDRIA
DOES HAVE A DRAMATIC LOOK HERE,
BUT I'M NOT BUYING IT.
WHAT IS SHE SAYING TO ME?
>> THE FACT THAT YOU
CAN'T SAY ANYTHING
SPEAKS VOLUMES TO THE FACT
THAT THERE REALLY ISN'T
MUCH GOING ON HERE.
I KNOW SHE LOOKS DRAMATIC,
AND, YOU KNOW,
BUT I THINK THAT'S THE CLOTHES.
HOWEVER, WHEN I GO IN CLOSE,
SHE LOOKS LIKE SHE WORKS
FOR THE NATIONAL AIRLINE
AS A FLIGHT ATTENDANT.
>> OH, YES!
>> THAT IS THE STORY.
>> I DON'T THINK SHE LOOKS
AS BAD AS YOU GUYS ARE SAYING.
SHE LOOKS LIKE, YOU KNOW,
AFRAID OF SOMETHING.
SHE LOOKS A BIT SCARED,
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S BAD.
>> MOLLY.
>> THIS IS SO HIGH FASHION.
I MEAN, I SEE THE CLOTHES
AND I SEE A STORY.
>> MOLLY HAS A GREAT CAPACITY
TO DO EDITORIAL PHOTOGRAPHY
AND ALSO SELL THE CLOTHING.
I MEAN, I SEE HER IN PERSON,
I DON'T GET THAT DRAMA,
SO I LOVE THAT CHAMELEON FACTOR.
YOU KNOW,
I KNOW SHE LOOKS DRAMATIC,
VERY TOUGH IN THE EYES,
BUT IN HER--IN HER FILM
WITH A--WITH A LITTLE BIT
MORE ROMANCE
IN SOME OF THE PICTURES.
>> SHE IS A TOUGH-FACED GIRL.
>> SHE IS.
>> THAT SEEMS TO BE HER THING.
SHE NEEDS TO MIX IT UP.
HANNAH.
>> IT'S A COOL PICTURE
OF HANNAH. I LIKE THE ANGLE.
IT'S SORT OF BOND GIRLISH.
I JUST NEED
A LITTLE BIT MORE ATTITUDE.
>> HANNAH LOOKS
VERY, VERY BEAUTIFUL,
BUT SOMEHOW THE FACE EXPRESSION
DOESN'T GO
WITH HER BODY LANGUAGE.
THAT'S WHAT I THINK.
>> I DO NOT LIKE THIS PICTURE--
NOT THE FACE.
>> HER FACE--IT DOESN'T ALSO
GO WITH THE BODY,
BUT I THINK SHE EVOKES
A KIND OF CHARM
THAT COULD BE TOTALLY ENGAGING.
>> BRITTANI.
>> SHE HAS MANAGED TO BREAK
HER BODY IN AN INTERESTING WAY.
>> SHE DEFINITELY LOOKS PRETTY.
IT'S AN INTERESTING BODY ANGLE.
BUT AGAIN, SHE HASN'T PUSHED
THE ENVELOPE, AND I THINK
AT THIS STAGE
IN THE COMPETITION,
YOU'RE LOOKING FOR GIRLS
TO JUMP OUTSIDE THE BOX.
>> YEAH.
>> GET SOAKING WET,
GET ON THE GROUND,
AND I KNOW THAT IT MIGHT RUIN
YOUR DRESS, BUT THERE'S
AN ELEMENT OF, LIKE,
TAKING THOSE SORTS OF RISKS.
>> I THINK BRITTANI LOOKS GREAT.
SHE LOOKS MUCH BETTER
IN THE PICTURE
THAN SHE DOES IN REAL LIFE.
>> WHICH IS GOOD FOR A MODEL.
SHE SHOULD ALWAYS LOOK BETTER.
WHENEVER PEOPLE GO, "TYRA,
YOU LOOK BETTER IN PERSON
THAN YOUR PICTURES"--
"DON'T SAY THAT, HONEY.
I MADE MY MONEY
OFF MY PICTURES."
I THINK THIS PHOTO IS NICE.
>> IT'S NICE.
>> IT'S SWEET.
>> BUT WE DON'T WANT NICE.
WE DON'T WANT NICE.
WE WANT DRAMA.
>> WE REACHED A DECISION.
>> HAVE WE?
WE HAVE.
>> WE HAVE.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> FOUR BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE
THREE PHOTOS IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT ARE
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
BEST PICTURE THIS WEEK...
>> I'D SAY IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS.
MOLLY, COME FORWARD.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS FABULOUS--
MODELING THE CLOTHES
AND SELLINGTHE CLOTHES.
BUT WHAT THE JUDGES WANT
TO SEE MORE OF FROM YOU
IS NOT THAT MEAN, INTENSE FACE
ALL THE TIME IN YOUR PHOTOS.
SO MIX IT UP.
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> (whispers) YOU'RE WELCOME.
(normal voice) RUNNER-UP
FOR BEST PHOTO IS...
>> BRITTANI.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS, BRITTANI.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (normal voice) THANK YOU.
>> WILL ALEXANDRIA AND HANNAH
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> TWO BEAUTIFUL YOUNG LADIES
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS STILL
IN THE RUNNING TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I'LL ONLY CALL ONE NAME.
AND THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY RETURN
TO HER HOME HERE,
PACK HER BELONGINGS,
AND GO HOME.
BLONDE GIRLS TEND TO GET
A BAD RAP.
A LOT OF PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY
IN THE FASHION INDUSTRY,
SAY, "OH, BLONDES, BLONDES--
THEY'RE ALL THE SAME.
THEY'RE ALL THE SAME,"
BUT I DISAGREE,
AND I THINK YOU, ALEXANDRIA,
AND YOU, HANNAH,
BOTH HAVE VERY INTERESTING
AND UNIQUE LOOKS
AND PERSONALITIES.
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS
THAT MAKE YOU ALL DIFFERENT
FROM EACH OTHER AS WELL.
ALEXANDRIA,
YOU--TOO MUCH CONTROL.
HOLDING ON
TO THE HANDLEBARS OF CONTROL
TO WHERE YOUR PHOTO THIS WEEK
DIDN'T LOOK HIGH FASHION.
ONE OF THE JUDGES SAID
THAT YOU LOOKED LIKE
A FLIGHT ATTENDANT.
AND THEN WE HAVE HANNAH,
THE COMPLETE OPPOSITE--
LACKS CONTROL.
SOMETIMES YOU GET
IN YOUR PHOTOS,
AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT HANNAH'S DOING.
AND THEN HANNAH'S FACE
DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT IT'S DOING EITHER.
SO WHO STAYS
IN THIS COMPETITION?
>> HANNAH.
>> (whispers indistinctly)
>> HANNAH,
YOU HAVE HAD
SOME OF THESTRONGEST PICTURES
IN THIS COMPETITION.
YOU HAVE HAD PICTURES
THAT HAVE TAKEN MY BREATH AWAY.
BUT YOU CAN'T BE SOMETIME-Y.
YOU HAVE TO BRING IT
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> (whispers) THANK YOU.
>> (whispers) YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> (whispers indistinctly)
>> (normal voice) OKAY.
SHAKE IT OUT. RELAX.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> A PLEASURE.
>> SO YOU HAVE TO RELAX.
>> YES.
>> OKAY? I LOOK AT YOUR FILM,
ESPECIALLY THIS WEEK,
AND IT'S THIS--
THIS MOUTH. (grunts)
>> (chuckles)
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT.
YOU HAVE BOOM, BOOM, BOOM,
BOOM, UHH, ANGLES.
JUST LET IT BE.
>> I WILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
(sniffles)
(crying) I FAILED MYSELF.
I DID MY BEST.
THIS IS WHAT I'D LOVE TO DO.
SO MAYBE THAT'S WHY
I WAS CONTROLLING TOO MUCH.
I'VE HAD A LOT OF UPs AND DOWNS
IN THIS COMPETITION.
LIKE, I WAS BEING
TOO CONTROLLING,
BUT I FEEL LIKE THIS IS
PROBABLY ONE OF
THE BEST LESSONS I'VE EVER HAD,
SO I'M JUST COMING OUT OF THIS
WITH SO MUCH MORE KNOWLEDGE
AND SO MUCH MORE EXPERIENCE,
AND I CAN'T WAIT TO GO USE IT.
♪♪♪♪♪
Captioned by
Closed Captioning Services, Inc.